indeed this is my fourth time here I I
don't know why I keep I keep getting
invited back I think each year the the
the talks getting more technical and
less accessible so maybe I'll keep I'll
continue that trend and then until I
don't get until I don't get invited back
or let's see if this thing you see if
this thing works does this work no aha
very good oh no the punchline so so this
month actually marks the it's been it's
been now over over ten years since I
started down the crazy path the rabbit
hole of building what are now called
data science tools they weren't called
they weren't called that back that they
weren't called that back then maybe I
shouldn't had a beer but so I started
writing the lines of code that became
the the pandas project in April in April
2008 and it's been kind of a wild kind
of a wild ride since then I handed over
the reins of the the project to you know
Geoffrey back and the other maintainer
Xand in 2013 and they've been doing a
great job the last five years you know
keeping the project you know growing and
healthy and that continues you know to
the to the present day I've gotten
involved in some other open-source
projects in the in the Apache Software
Foundation started a couple of other
small projects wrote a book did a second
dition I had a startup so it's been the
it's been an interesting and interesting
ride I I'm still here I'm still I'm
still building data science tools so I
haven't been you know I haven't been
thrown off the train quite quite yet but
I've spent a lot of time thinking about
the you know now with the perspective of
looking at the last the last ten years
and how far we've come with open source
data science tools and my theme you know
if you look at my talks here at the arc
conference the last two or three years
I've been spending a lot of time
thinking about you know where are we
going over the next ten years over the
next 20 years and how can we plan and
work together to to build a better
you know a better future for for
ourselves and so I wrote I wrote a talk
at the end of 2013 I gave it at PI data
NYC and the title of the talk was 10
things I hate about pandas and so I you
know like as as we've been building the
into the software you you know you know
about all of the things that are not
good and so I've tried to kind of
distill all of that learning and
complaints and grievances and turn it
into something productive and maybe
build some useful some useful software
that can put us on a better better
trajectory to build better data science
tools in the future so so one one step
that I've just taken this this year is
so I've founded an organization called
Ursa labs hopefully the reason behind
the name should be should be obvious but
in general funding open source software
is very complicated and it's it's tough
because people struggle with giving
money to fund open-source developers so
I think there's you know like many
people they just they download the
software they use it but they don't
think a lot about how is that software
produced like who are the people that
are that are producing it and it has
been incredibly difficult for
individuals who are building projects to
obtain full time you know no strings
attached support for for building for
building the projects that they're that
they're most passionate about and I
personally have been through several
iterations of different approaches to
obtaining sustainable sustainable
funding to work on to work on my
projects including including pandas and
you know pandas was primarily Funt was
self-funded it came out of money out of
my own pocket and money that I could
have been making doing consulting or
working in a you know here in New York
and a financial firm so I'd be much
wealthier if I did not work on open
source software but I just felt it was
the right thing to do and I was willing
to make willing to make that sacrifice
I've done some other things I've done
consulting supported open source
development I
found a venture-backed startup with the
intent of you know funneling rnd time
back into the open source ecosystem that
brought with it its own challenges and
and kind of difficulties that come with
you know that come with startup so I've
worked on open source projects within
inside a larger company so last four
years I've been I've been with cloud era
and and with two sigma so this so
starting a lab so I'm partnering up with
with with our studio to to build the lab
so get to work formally with mr. Hadley
Wickham you know for the for the first
time we've worked together and formally
in the past but this will be the first
time that we get to work on a project
together but the idea is that we are you
know creating an organization to be able
to raise to raise money from companies
that depend on open source data science
tools and that money will be used
directly to fund salary and benefits for
full-time developers who or who are
building projects to make the whole you
know Python are you know general data
science ecosystem stronger and better
I've last few years I've been building a
project a helping build a project called
Apache arrow so a lot of this work will
be based on on arrow for some reasons
that I will talk about over the next 15
minutes and the goal is to create
software that is portable and promotes
collaboration and software use across
the data science world so that we aren't
simply solving problems that our
programmers however the Python
programmers have that we're creating
reusable software that can benefit the
entire open-source data science world
and I think that as time goes on it will
get easier and easier for for that
collaboration to to happen so so I'm the
director of the lab Hadley is advising
and making sure that I make fewer
mistakes and that the needs of the our
community are are looked after and we
are going to work together to because
really you know if you look at what
Hadley and I do we design we think about
the human interface with data and so a
lot of people thought oh well Haley and
I are you
we should be enemies because we build
Python and our tools but really what we
do is we look at how data scientists
work and we want to make their lives
better it's like how can we make the
individual more productive able to spend
you know more time thinking about data
science and solving problems less time
thinking about code so if we can
translate our ideas about working with
data into code that is easy to reason
about and easy to write that makes you
know the whole you know the whole world
more productive and more effective and
so over the years you know he and I have
have bonded over our kind of passion for
making people more productive working
with data and so I think you know
collaborating on on these projects will
you know the whole will be greater than
the sum of its parts for sure so the
last couple of years I've been with two
sigma so they're they're sponsoring and
and important helping support support
this work our studio is is taking on the
administrative burden of operating the
lab so so when I so when I hire people
into the lab they will make that a lot
easier on me so that I do not have to
spend all my time running a company and
we are you know going to be fundraising
and looking for more sponsors and and
development partners to to get involved
so if you have a budget for sponsoring
open source and would be interested in
and getting involved please please get
in touch
we love to we'd love to hear from you so
now let's get into some slightly more
technical matter so my talks here the
last two are New York our conferences
have been about arrow you know it
started out like here's a project that
just started here's some pie-in-the-sky
ideas that we're really excited about
last year it was hey we've made some
progress on those ideas and now we've
made a lot more progress and so things
are starting to get really really
exciting so I think a year from now if
I'm invited back I'll have I'll have
more more to tell about about what's
going on but but the idea of the project
is that we I I identified in my work on
on pandas a lot of problems that I was I
was running into
you know how do I share data with this
data processing system or you know why
am I having to reinvent the wheel to
read CSV files and to read data out of
databases efficiently and so you know
kind of if you look at the pandas
project it's this whole world unto
itself where we've had to solve all of
these data access data manipulation
computational problems for ourselves we
aren't able to take code from the our
world and reuse it or code from the Java
world and reuse it and so I kind of
drill down and said you know how can we
build some technology that could enable
us to share data and share algorithms
more easily so I spent while I was at
Cloudera I spent about a year trying to
get get folks together kind of get a
band together to to build a project to
see if people also agreed other people
agreed that this was a problem luckily
they did and we were able to you know
get together you know 25 or 30
open-source developers to create the you
know to create the Aero project and
we've been growing the the team the team
since then so one of the highest and the
biggest you know kind of most important
use cases for for Apache Aero is you
know what I called defragmenting data
access so if you think about the problem
well you've got all these computational
systems all of these data storage
formats data access points the points of
contact for data access so there's a lot
of energy loss dealing with like how do
I get data from point A to point B how
do I convert between one systems memory
representation and another systems
memory representation and so legacy
systems still may use a native memory
memory representation that is not Aero
but they can retrofit themselves to be
able to support Aero export and import
and that will make things a lot simpler
for systems that want to plugin that
also speak speak aero and as time goes
on when new data processing engines are
developed we we expect and hope that
systems will choose choose Aero as their
native format for for analytics in in
memory so I think if this is the
portable data frame problem so you know
we say data frame like you know our data
frame pandas dataframe giulia data frame
but if you drill down below just the
language into the technical details of
like when I say data frame like what
actually is that thing if you look in
you know the DRAM in your computer how
has that memory arranged in you know
virtual address space and an our data
frame at that level is completely
different from a panda's data frame it's
completely different from a spark data
frame and so forth so the idea of arrow
is to define a language independent data
frame representation that is suitably
general to address you know 99% of use
cases for data frame like tools and have
native implementations across the gamut
of programming languages that are used
to build data science tools so if we are
in the python r ecosystem we can write
code in c c++ if you're in you know a
different ecosystem you might be writing
code in java or rust or go or javascript
so so arrow is not specific to any any
programming language so there's some
some major use cases where the project
is is getting picked up and in the world
so one is as a primary runtime memory
format for analytics so when you load
data from files or you pull data out of
databases to do some data manipulations
or perform some analytics the data is
arranged in memory and arrow format and
so then you run your algorithms on on on
the arrow memory and what's exciting
about having this runtime format is that
if I have an algorithm that knows how to
process arrow memory that that algorithm
is automatically reusable so you know
it's very difficult right now if I write
an algorithm that processes a panda's
data frame I can't take that code and
process an our data frame because the
memory is different
using the same technology we've been
developing tools to enable data to be
shared between processes without copying
so this is about making it really cheap
and easy to access very large data sets
and to blur the boundary between data
and memory and data on disk so if you
have a really huge data set that is on
your laptop on a solid-state drive maybe
it's a terabyte of data maybe it's 100
gigabytes of data maybe there's only a
small chunk of that data that you want
to use to for your analysis with a lot
of data serialization tools in order to
access that subset of data for your
analysis you have to read the whole data
set so if it might be like the middle of
a CSV file so you have to parse the
whole CSV file before you can get that
middle chunk so arrow makes that that
problem go away where you can just you
know access only the data that you need
and you can get access to that very
cheaply we've been using we've been
using arrow to build file formats so you
may have heard of this thing called
feather that that Hadley and I made so
that was a first example of building a
file format that that uses arrow and I
think that I think that we'll see more
of that that sort of thing you know
develop and in the next couple of years
and so I know in the our world there's a
there's another competing file format
with feather called
called FST and so the way I would
contrast or way I would describe FST is
as an evolved version of feather that
can only be read and R and so from my
point of view like having file formats
that can be read in any programming
languages is a you know kind of that's
that's really what I would what I would
like to see one of the biggest the the
project has grown so much is it's no
longer just about data frames and
columnar data but the columnar data
format is one of the biggest parts of
the project where we spent the most time
designing a suitably general and
efficient data frame representation for
for analytics so I won't go through
these details but these are things you
can read more about we've been building
libraries in many programming languages
so we started out with Java and C++ we
now have a native JavaScript
implementation it's really cool it can
you can generate if an aero file and in
Java or Python and send it to the
browser and read it without doing any
parsing so it doesn't go through JSON or
any of that and and that's really neat
we just received a donation of a go
implementation which was created by
influx data which which builds in flux
DV I need to update this diagram because
we
have a burgeoning rust native rust
implementation which is really cool I
know there's also a Julia implementation
somewhere in the ether that I hope can
get merged into the end of the Apache
project and we've been building bindings
so I've been working on with you know
many other people on Python bindings
there's also Ruby bindings which are
kind of it's like kind of a conception
where it's like bindings on bindings so
Ruby is going through C which is talking
to C++ so you know it's you know you
have bindings to bindings to bindings
starting to see Aero used in some pretty
cool applications so if you follow work
happening in the Berkeley Ryze lab which
is oriented around real time secure
machine learning they've developed a
machine learning framework called ray
which uses they developed a shared
memory object store for managing data
that flows between tasks in a in a
reinforcement learning setting and so
that object store is called plasma and
they donated that to the to the Aero
project and it's become a tightly
integrated component so that we can see
more machine learning systems built on
top of the mantra of free data access
and shared and shared memory which these
libraries make make so you know much
simpler than doing it doing it by hand
many companies in industry have been
have been contributing to the
contributing to the project so I won't
go through all of them so it's really
great to see you know some bigger
companies you know like folks from
Brooks from Intel and HP and you know so
I've been I've been contributing through
through to Sigma and of course I was a
cloud era before that but this is you
know we're getting a lot of inbound
interest and I think you know over the
course of this year and next year I
think we'll see a major uptick in kind
of an investment from from from the big
tech companies who they want to support
Aero in their and their systems we're up
to 140 contributors on github this is
our kind of JIRA burndown chart it turns
out that not everyone uses JIRA but you
can see that we kind of got off to a
slow start and then there was an
election point at the end of last middle
of last year and so it's been kind of
you know kind of to the moon since then
I think that trend will will continue
over over the next over that couple of
years we've made nine major releases so
I'm not going to bore you with the
details of what these releases but just
want to give you a flavor of what's
coming in the project and how it's
relevant to today's science users so
let's talk about computational libraries
because at the end of the day what this
is about for data science users is
making data access a great deal faster
and more efficient making it easier to
use multiple programming languages so if
you want to use Python and art together
this technology makes that much Neos
unit you know much simpler and so I
don't know if you saw the reticulate
package from our studio which provides
python integration and R so having you
know kind of arrow support to be able to
move data between Python and R will make
that whole stack a great deal more
powerful so at a high level you know the
way I think about the problem having
worked in this ecosystem for a long time
is that Python and are built on this
computational foundation that was
established in the mid-1990s we're
looking backward from say 1995 everyone
was programming in Fortran and it was
you know you said hey wouldn't it be
great if we had interpreted programming
languages that could manipulate the same
code the same linear algebra libraries
multi-dimensional arrays that we're
using in Fortran but we could do so in
an interactive interpreted environment
so hence we had numpy developed in
Python and equivalent types of tools in
R but there's a lot of problems with the
the computational systems that perform
analytics in memory so a lot of the
algorithms are single threaded there
isn't a great deal of you know the
execution model the way that algorithms
are evaluated is is very much you know
one step at a time there's a lot of
temporary data that's produced so so
there's a bunch of problems there and
what's happening is that you look in the
Python Antartica system and people are
you know if your data is small
everything's fine and so it turns out
that a lot of people have small data and
this is just not an issue but as soon as
you start getting into you
the tens or hundreds of gigabytes of
data you start to get into into
struggles Ville and so and I've been
there and really you think about where
things are going we've got these
machines with tons of RAM tons of like
very fast solid-state drives and loss of
cores we should be able to work with 100
gigabyte data sets on a laptop without
even thinking twice about it and so
that's that's the world that I'd like to
I'd like to get to so to have Oliver as
many of our algorithms be multi-core GPU
accelerated we have all this fancy code
generation stuff that we can employ to
make things even even faster there's a
lot of there's a lot of sophistication
that we can bring to the table and a lot
of this comes directly out of the
analytic database world so it's not like
we even have to reinvent wheels we just
look at what the database world is doing
and we adapt those ideas for for data
science use cases so there's a wealth of
literature and learning that we can that
we can bring to to the everyday lives of
of data scientists so so what a lot of
the work I'm running out of time but a
lot of work the next couple of years
we'll be building computational
libraries that that process the arrow
memory format so these will be native
code libraries that are that create
shared libraries C C++ shared libraries
so we can use them in Python we can use
them in R we can use them in Java
through j'ni bindings you know I think
we'll see computational libraries build
and rust and other languages and so
those could also be brought brought to
the table so all this will be portable
code that can be used in any and any
programming language it's plenty of
other stuff we got to do you know we got
to read CSV files everyone loves to read
CSV files but it it has to happen
because it's really important but you
know my goal in the long in the long run
and where I hope you know we we see
ourselves in a decade is that we have
you know portable high quality high
performance libraries that we can that
we can develop the front end that suits
us whether that's an our front end or a
Python front end and we have the you
know the same quality of you know
experience and performance and
scalability regardless of what
programming language we're using so
that's that's all I'm sorry for
for running over time but you know with
so with Ursa Labs I will have a lot more
time and more leverage to work on these
problems so that's super exciting I have
about like a 15 page
tech vision document that you can read
all about this stuff
so I've I've been thinking about these
problems for a really long time so maybe
you'll have some ideas and I'd love to
I'd love to hear from you and I if you'd
like to get involved in the development
the the best way is to get involved in
the Apache aero project which is on
github and you know we're there to help
and we'd love to we'd love to have you
involved
it is systems work so it's you know it's
a lot lower level than a lot of the work
that the data's data scientists
experienced day to day but I found that
I quite I quite liked the systems work
so so that's good thank you all
[Applause]
you